we're closing in fast on back to school
time one subject parents are really
focused on will there actually be enough
teachers yeah staffing shortages were
certainly a big issue during the last
school year so we wanted to see how
things were looking heading into the new
year madison kimbrell live in our
newsroom with the big goal from the
superintendent
according to the clark county school
district's website there are more than
1400 teacher positions available with
the most in need is elementary schools i
spoke with teachers on their
expectations and concerns for the
upcoming school year
it's going to be a unique year i think
last year was very challenging and i
think for a lot of us a repeat of last
year is what we're not hoping for
educators like las vegas high school
teacher ryan fremoltz expressing his
hope for the upcoming school year and
with that comes a much needed change
when it comes to staffing superintendent
dr jesus jarrah making it his goal to
hire more than 600 new teachers before
november first back in march of this
year about 1300 teachers left the
district and while staff does come and
go it is concerning to dr jarrah as the
district has not been fully staffed in
almost 30 years we know that most
schools will not be fully staffed
come august we know a lot of schools
especially in the ones with many
openings
are going to be short
a quarter or even a third of their staff
nevada now only requiring a high school
diploma for substitute teachers for
full-time ccsd teachers returning this
fall like emily kurtz the support she
has at her school is why she wants to
continue teaching but says a lot of
fellow colleagues within the district
weren't so lucky you know teachers that
have put 20 years into this district
and just mentally couldn't do it anymore
and emotionally i think that my admin
has done a great job at like showing
appreciation i think that it would have
to be up on the next step of showing
respect to the teachers that did stay
and i do think that the bonus was a
great start to that but i also think
that maybe a salary adjustment instead
of a one-time bonus would be nice
and i reached out to the school district
to find out how many teachers have
retired or quit since may i'm waiting
for that number that the top three
schools with the highest vacancies are
kelly elementary school escobedo middle
school and finlay middle school that's
going to be in north las vegas in the
newsroom madison kimbrough live local
now